antes de denis istomin hoy comenzó
oficialmente la vacunación masiva contra
el cob y 19 en la unión europea 12 5
millones de dosis desarrolladas por
facer y valiente aunque alemania hungría
y eslovaquia se adelantaron un día el
lanzamiento conjunto de este domingo es
para enviar un mensaje unificado de que
la vacuna es segura y de que es el
comienzo del fin de la pandemia
sabemos que la pandemia no desaparecerá
a partir de hoy pero la vacuna es el
comienzo de la victoria sobre esta
pandemia
la vacuna cambia el juego fuiste tú
quien ya por eso muchos lo llaman el
'día v por vacunación y aludiendo al día
de la victoria de los aliados en la
segunda guerra mundial en francia
morissette de 78 años fue la primera en
vacunarse allí el gobierno ha sido
cauteloso con su mensaje para no generar
más dudas en quienes cuestionan la
seguridad de las dosis
la vacuna no será obligatoria tengamos
confianza en nuestros investigadores y
médicos somos la tierra de la luz y de
pasteur la razón y la ciencia deben
guiarnos
las inyecciones también se aplican en
italia españa portugal entre otros en
grecia y república checa- los primeros
en ponerse la vacuna fueron los
mandatarios nacionales bélgica y
luxemburgo empezarán mañana y en países
bajos la espera será la más larga pues
los neerlandeses no podrán vacunarse
hasta el 8 de enero ya que su sistema
para registrar las dosis no estará listo
para 2020